The crapper.
John.
Dunny.
Latrine.
Loo.
Porcelain throne.
Potty.
There are more than one hundred words for
toilet, but did you know that more people
have cellphones than a place to go poo?
Hey there science fans!
Dr. Kiki from This Week in Science here for
DNews.
A study in the Public Library of Science journal
PLoS One this week investigated the sanitation
habits of Lasius niger, otherwise called black
garden ants.
On observing colonies of the ants in the laboratory,
the researchers noticed what looked like dark
patches in the corners.
To see whether the patches were indoor lavatories,
they fed the ants colored food.
The result is hard to deny… the ants dedicate
special areas within their homes for defecation.
But, why would ants use a toilet when the
whole world could be their bathroom?
Humans and other animals tend to separate
the places where they eat and socialize from
the places where they defecate.
The reason for this is thought to be mainly
for sanitation.
Excrement, feces, what you might call poop,
has the potential to harbor pathogenic bacteria
and parasites.
Human feces is known to contain E. coli, which
causes disease.
Highly populated areas with poor or no sanitation
often suffer from devastating water-borne
diseases because people live too close to
waterways, and excrement gets into the drinking
water supply.
So, good health and survival depend on the
drive to not poop where you eat.
Social insects, like ants, have been observed
in many studies removing waste materials from
their nests.
And, like humans, it’s thought to keep things
clean, and provide for the health of the colony.
Honey bees take their defecation outside,
and like to poop as they fly.
Bee larvae don’t actually poop until they
take their first flight, letting the waste
build up inside of them until they become
adult bees and are old enough to venture outside
alone.
Adult cockroaches collect poop from their
nests and dump it outside.
But, there are wood-boring beetles who just
fill old, unused tunnels with their bodily
refuse.
In this study the ants continued to remove
other solid waste to the outside, adding strength
to the conclusion that these patches were
actually toilets.
However, the ants did not seem to avoid the
toilet area, so the researchers wondered whether
the indoor toilets might serve some additional
beneficial purpose, like providing healthful
bacteria to young ants.
Leaf-cutter ants fertilize their gardens with
their poop.
Termites use their fecal matter to build their
homes.
And, some ants use poo to not only mark their
territories, but also identify themselves
as part of the group by wiping it on walls
and themselves.
Then there are insects like the dung beetle
who need the poop from herbivorous and omnivorous
animals to survive.
They are attracted to and collect the poop
from large creatures for use as food and a
place to raise their young.
Although, at least one species lays its eggs
on the mother’s own poop.
If you are wondering after all this talk about
poop, whether insects like ants pee, the answer
is that they do a little of both every time
they defecate.
What we think of as pee, is our body’s way
to get rid of excess water, salts, and urea,
which is liquid nitrogen waste.
Insects don’t have a lot of excess water
remaining from their metabolic functions to
excrete, and tend to produce an insoluble
solid called uric acid that gets mixed into
the digestive waste via the Malphigian tubules
and pooped out the anus as a substance called
frass.
It’s not really known whether by not making
liquid pee insects are conserving water, or
if turning it into a solid helps with weight
regulation since a water containing bladder
would be big and heavy to carry around.
And, if you want to know about the weirdest
not pee out there, woodlice, which are not
insects but crustaceans, get rid of excess
nitrogen in a puff of ammonia gas through
their exoskeleton.
Anything else you wanna know about insect
bathroom habits?